have you ever thought about how
incredible the human body is for example
just to name a few things that your
body's already been doing today you're
using your lungs to take breaths in and
out your heart's beating without
stopping and your brain is coordinating
your body's functions and at the same
time helping you understand this video
all these body parts are made up of
cells which as you might remember are
the smallest units of life and it's so
amazing that trillions of cells without
thoughts or intentions of their own can
come together to form something as
complex as the human body
to help us understand how this occurs we
have to understand how the body is
organized the human body has a
hierarchical organization meaning it's
made up of nested layers each one more
complex than the last in this case four
different layers make up this hierarchy
cells which make up tissues tissues
which make up organs organs which make
up organ systems and finally organ
systems which help the human body
function as a whole
so let's start with cells and tissues
cells are the smallest unit of life and
the most basic level of organization in
the human body in the human body not all
cells look or work the same instead
they're specialized to carry out
different functions after cells the next
level of organization is tissues a
tissue is a collection of similar
specialized cells and all of the cells
that make up a tissue are like a team
they work together to ensure the tissue
works properly for instance this image
shows a section of the type of
epithelial tissue that lines the inside
of your mouth this particular tissue is
made up of epithelial cells which are
specialized to help protect your mouth
from wear and tear so the next time
you're eating a pointy tortilla chip
remember how important this epithelial
tissue is
next up are organs and organ systems so
organs are structures that are made up
of multiple different types of tissues
which all work together to help the
organ function and an organ system is a
group of organs that work together to
carry out complex functions for the body
for instance the lungs shown here in the
diagram are made up of several tissue
types that help them expand and contract
these tissue types include epithelial
tissue which is the same type of tissue
we talked about earlier in the mouth and
connective tissue and these tissues work
together so that the lungs can carry out
their role in the respiratory system
which is the organ system that allows us
to respire or breathe the respiratory
system is made up of multiple organs
including the lungs the trachea the nose
and the diaphragm when we breathe our
diaphragm which is this muscle right
here contracts
air is pulled through our nose and
trachea and into our lungs
here gas exchange happens and our bodies
take in oxygen and get rid of carbon
dioxide then our diaphragm relaxes and
we exhale
the respiratory system and other organ
systems in the body carry out specific
functions but work together to keep us
alive and they do this mostly without us
even realizing it
so it might get a little tricky to
remember how all four levels of
organization
cells tissues organs and organ systems
relate to each other
i like to think of these four different
levels almost like the russian nesting
dolls that fit one inside another with
cells being the smallest doll on the
inside so cells make up tissues tissues
make up organs
and organs make up organ systems all of
these components come together to make
up the human body
so i hope you've learned more about how
our bodies organization helps us thrive
and stay alive so now use your brain to
tell your muscular system to move your
arm and give yourself a pat on the back
because your body and its organized
hierarchical system is really awesome